humans are intelligent and they're uh
introspective and they can reflect on
the experiences of their life so for
example there's been many years in my
life where i i ate an excessive amount
of sugar and then a certain moment i
woke up and said uh
why do i keep doing this this doesn't
feel good
i like long term and i think
uh so going through the tick tock
process of realizing
okay when i shorten my attention span
actually that does not make me feel good
longer term
and realizing that and then going to
platforms
going to places that
um
are away from the sugar so so in in so
doing you can create platforms that can
make a lot of money when so to help
people wake up to what actually makes
them feel good long term develop grow as
human beings and it just feels like
humans are more intelligent than
uh mice looking for cheese they're able
to sort of think i mean we can think we
can contemplate our mortality right and
contemplate things like
long-term
love and we can have a long-term fear of
certain things like mortality we can
contemplate whether the
experiences the sort of the drugs of
daily life that we've been partaking in
is making us happier a better people and
then once we contemplate that we can
make financial decisions in using
services and paying for services that
are making us better people so it just
seems that
we're in the very first stages of social
networks
that just were able to make a lot of
money really quickly but in
bringing out sometimes
the bad parts of human nature they
didn't destroy humans they just they
just fed everybody a lot of sugar and
now everyone's gonna wake up and say
hey we're gonna start having like
sugar-free social media right
right well there's a lot to unpack there
i think some people certainly have the
capacity for that and i certainly think
i mean it's very interesting even the
way you said it you woke up one day and
you thought well this doesn't feel very
good yeah well that's still your limbic
system saying this doesn't feel very
good
right you have a cat brains worth of
neurons around your gut right and so
maybe that exaggerated and that was
telling you hey this isn't good
humans are
more than just mice looking for cheese
or monkeys looking for sex and power
right so
let's slow down now you're um now a lot
of people would argue with you on that
one but we're more than just that but
we're at least that and we're
very very seldom not that
so um my i don't actually disagree with
you that we could be better and that we
can that better platforms exist and
people are voluntarily noping out of
things like facebook and opening up
awesome verb it's a great term yeah i
love it i use it all the time
you're
it's gonna be a hard pass and
and that's and that's that's great but
that's again to your point that's the
first generation of front-facing cameras
of social pressures and you as a you
know self-starter self-aware adult have
the capacity to say yeah i'm not going
to do that i'm going to go and spend
time on long-form reads i'm going to
spend time managing my attention i'm
going to do some yoga
if you're a 15 year old in high school
and your entire social environment is
everyone doing these things guess what
you're going to do
you're going to kind of have to do that
because your limbic system says hey i
need to get the guy or the girl or
whatever and that's what i'm going to do
and so one of the things that we have to
reason about here is the social media
systems or you know social media i think
is a
first
our first encounter with
a technological system
that runs a bit of a loop around
our own cognition and attention
it's not the last
it's it's far from the last
and it gets to the heart of some of the
philosophical achilles heel
of the western philosophical system
which is each person gets to make their
own determination each person is an
individual that's you know sacrosanct in
their agency and their sovereignty and
all these things
the problem with these systems is they
come down and they are able to manage
everyone on mass
and so every person is making their own
decision but together the the bigger
system is causing them to act with a
group
um dynamic that's very profitable for
people
so this is the issue that we have is
that our philosophies are actually not
geared to understand what is it for a
person to be to have an uh
high trust connection
uh as part of a collective and for that
collective to have its right to
coherency and agency
that's something like when when a social
media app causes a family to break apart
it's done harm to more than just
individuals
right so that concept is not something
we really talk about or think about very
much but that's actually the problem is
that we're vaporizing molecules into
atomic units and then we're hitting all
the atoms with certain things that's
like yeah well that person chose to look
at my app
so our understanding of human nature is
at the individual level it emphasizes
the individual too much because
ultimately society operates at the
collective level and these apps do as
well and the apps do as well so for us
to understand the progression and the
development of this organism we call
human civilization we have to think of
the collective level too i would say
multi-tiered multi-tiered multi so
individual as well individuals family
units social collectives
um and on the way up
you